gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus
we've played the Leo IG with the crowd
shows are selling out and you can get
your tickets at rugarbage.com see you
there
[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that out there to be classy
into just a big old piece of trash I'm
your host Dave trolley coming at you on
a beautiful day we're out back at
hoodies here in the new edition she's
upstairs doing a little gardening okay
gotta grow operation up there in the
back closet a lot of tinfoil going
through hope the chopper don't fly over
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he's a king of the boardwalk baby and
not too bad Under the Boardwalk I'll
tell you that right now give it up for
KJ Kevin James Ryan That was supposed to
be a secret what's up everybody thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate view subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube I know those
numbers are cooking and then obviously
the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com you go over there you
get all your bonus content check it out
guys yes sir how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the Magic Man embodies the summer with
his cut off shorts and a skimboard give
it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up dude what's
up people I'm stoked we got it's crazy
to see this guy not on my phone and
every time I owe my phone it's this guy
killing it got one of the [__] cool
kids yeah Bucky sees the flip-flops it's
my kind of dude
gang the long hair ain't lying because
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredible huh and I mean incredibly
special guests here with us today for
the first time he's a very funny very
successful stand-up comedian podcaster
and social media Superstar he's got a
brand new podcast thank you come again
he's got an amazing twitch stream little
dinky news and he's got to kick off a
fall tour in September give it up for
Jay durena everybody
[Laughter]
oh yeah you guys could get a live stream
on there just talking [__] and then
you'll get banned like everyone else
yeah I don't know anything about that
was one that came along and I was like
I'm done you're like I'm not learning
this one not into it there's kind of two
lanes you either go like I'm hardcore
good at playing video games or you're
like a chick with like great tits I got
one right here
[Laughter]
you shoot from here that's it that's it
you got a little experience on chat
roulette if that counts uh buddy give us
the back story fill us in where'd you
grow up give us the whole scoop right on
what's the origin story so I'm Canadian
I grew up on the west coast of Canada
like vancouver-ish area okay but like in
the suburbs boring ass [__] place how
far from Vancouver maybe like an hour
outside of Vancouver proper suburbs yeah
north of Lake Seattle yes north of
Seattle yeah
so is that above Mexico you would say if
I got a map out can we figure it out
that's like that thing in Team America
World Police where they're like Cairo
how many miles far from America like
everything is in comparison
Yeah you mentioned man oh Seattle you're
saying yeah yeah so grew up there
um like not not and nothing too crazy
going over there I was just kind of like
a a probably an alcoholic like 14. uh
yeah my kind of kid yeah it's getting
real go get her
hey start them young out there I was
just like partying for most of my high
school everything before that was like
kind of like Digimon and Pokemon
man this kid's cool talk about the
duality of a man so I put my Pokemon
cards away and said hello to Jack
Daniels yeah started drinking floaters
dude one Digimon Pokemon Jager Bomb
get a couple of those once I had a drink
and touched hits it was like whoa yeah
really changes your perspective on life
you come online man
system activated
upstairs and burn all your Pokemon cards
Pokemon cards gives me nothing to me now
what'd your mom and dad do uh my dad an
electrician my mom was in sales nice uh
my dad's from Haiti so okay I've traded
over uh they both were in their second
marriage when they met me so they had
okay two my dad had two kids my mom had
one kid so my sister on my mom's side we
all grew up together nice well like me
and her grew up together my brother and
sister my dad said we're in Montreal
which is like on the other in Canada
okay way on the other side that's above
New York yeah
just kidding just get my bearings over
to Ohio
they grew up with their mom over there
they grew up with their mom then when I
was like six or seven my brother came
over and started Living with us and then
my sister and my uh dad's side still
stayed in Montreal man we are in the
weeds already yeah welcome to the show
baby dude it was like people moving
around yeah
and then my sister on my dad said didn't
move over to way later I was like 14 or
15 by the time she came over and what's
the age separation what's the age
separation between your mom's first kids
so I'm the youngest kid my sister on my
mom's side's nine years older my sister
on my dad's side's nine years older my
brother is 10 years older so I'm the
youngest you're the baby yeah so when
you were a kid and they started moving
in they were like teenagers teenagers
yeah yeah everyone's like they are
established got their life's
personalities and all that kind of [__]
a little chaotic in the house like my
parents probably should have got
divorced like 10 years before they did
sure yeah shout out to staying together
yeah I [__] a lot of us that makes a
lot of comedians
it's like a linebacker Factory bro it
was like beneficial to me as a kid
because I [__] hated school and did
[__] all in school like I was like just
coasting on everything and my parents
would be like yo where's the report card
I'd be like oh they just didn't send it
but they were like having such just
discrepancies in their marriage that
they couldn't focus on my shortcomings
because they were fighting so I remember
like taking a report card getting it
from the mailbox before they could get
it and like bearing it in a field
what the [__] what's that report card
ever do to you I had to move it a couple
years later because I started developing
the land
they put on an addition I had to show up
remember that thing a couple years ago I
gotta go take care of it oh Jesus dude
burying your report card I had no idea
where else to put it I was just like bro
this is why I ripped its teeth out
Kevin's fingers in the freezer
ah okay all right then yeah so you did
you recognize that of like oh this is
kind of chaotic in here no one's really
paying attention I just don't have to
make if I don't make waves I can fly
another way exactly I was just flying
under the radar and then once I
graduated high school which I barely
graduated okay I went into my final exam
with 51 in English and you need your
English to graduate it's real wonky up
there real wonky like you you because we
don't do we do ABC we don't do D's or
any of that kind of [__] passed there
really yeah it's all like a percentage
system and I think everything you need
like at least grade 11 or what do you
guys say 11th grade
yeah I was lost
wait is a c up there still a c down here
I think or is that like an F so a c we
have C minus would be like an f a c
minus is like what percentage point
would that be that would be like you're
at like between like 50 and 55 okay that
would be like an effort yeah yeah okay
so are you need it it looks better on oh
yeah yeah 100 but you need at least that
little bit to graduate when to the final
with 51 came out with 50. so like I
think my English teacher was literally
like I just don't want to [__] see
this yeah exactly I'm sending him then I
don't want to get buried in the backyard
report
then I uh I went to college
um before College I took I found the
most [__] course because my parents
were like you got to go straight to
University or straight to college like
you we're not you're not taking a year
off because they saw I thought you're
translating for Americans yeah I went
straight to university college but we
have there's a there's a difference for
us we have like college and university
which I think you guys call everything
college now we got we have colleges and
universities but they're pretty much the
the meaning has changed over the years
universities offer uh uh Masters courses
yeah also a university is a collection
of colleges too ah I believe like the
whatever School of whatever and whatever
School whatever is in a university
gotcha I could be completely wrong yeah
fully nailed it no [__] yeah wow yeah
Masters and that Masters and phds to be
University okay okay
which he has neither one of by the way I
don't know how you learned that Snapple
fact give me a [__] C minus
now what'd you study uh I took a scuba
diving instructor
in the middle of Canada yeah
dude hey you better put your wetsuit on
it's cold out there today I'll tell you
that boy oh yeah that's insane I didn't
think anybody ever did that yeah yeah so
I did a scuba diving instructor course
it was like the most [__] course I
could find because I didn't want to do
school anymore I just wanted to [__] off
and so I forgot my flippers I can't go
to school today
it was it was pretty it was like it was
a fun course like he I just learned how
to become a scuba diving instructor get
the [__] out of here do you have any
scuba diving experience prior to
becoming an instructor zero zero so like
all my experience was all like cold
water diving unlike western Canada okay
so you dabbled in this a little bit yes
all right so like the course was eight
months and you did like I think I got
like a hundred and something Dives and
in that time to become an instructor
that's not college no no no that's
training yeah yeah it was like it was
basically a means to an end I could get
a job and then once I was an instructor
I could [__] off so then right after
that I moved to Mexico like a month like
19 took off to Mexico and then I lived
in Mexico for three years like teaching
scuba diving so you learned all this
stuff oh yeah it was actually legit yeah
it was legit I mean 100 Dives you gotta
yeah you gotta learn you got to know
what you're doing yeah you were out in
the in the in the cold water cold as
water you do like dry suit stuff so that
you're not actually getting wet you
still get cold down there because you
can feel it through your suit but the
like transfer of heat isn't as fast so
you just like you you don't freeze to
death dude that's pretty [__] there's
a lot of money in that oh oh there's
time like if you want to do like deep
sea diving or like deep sea welding and
[__] you can make crazy money I knew
every Dirtbag I know goes I'm gonna be a
deep sea welder you know how much money
they make a year anybody like takes
years off your life years because that
really the bends [__] like the nitrogen
in your system your body can't handle
that [__] but you can retire it like did
you ever get the bends no no no no I
never got the bags you had to put in the
chamber you gotta get you gotta [__] up
real bad to get the bends especially
like recreational diving I was just
doing like fun [__] you're looking at
like turtles and like you're playing
Pokemon yeah you're just like hanging
out I was hungover a lot when I went to
work early yeah like well because I was
like I was teaching diving from like 19
to 21. I was like parting in Mexico
where'd you get all the gear I I so like
that's got to be expensive right that
was part of the course of my parents
were like we'll pay for your school
whatever you do so you said hey I don't
really want to go to college per se and
study like Communications your English I
want to become a scuba diving instructor
yeah and they were like cool because you
had kind of done stuff like that they
were like cool because I had zero
interest in anything ever and they're
like at least he's doing something how
much lights at each other
the young one wants to swim whatever
yeah all they had to do was say hey you
hear what Mom said about you yeah what
were you so you were doing this in high
school uh how did you get into doing
free Dives in the cold water so I never
had done anything football team or
anything up there
skateboarding or something like that I
never did any sort of scuba diving
training before the course yeah they
learned the first time Oh I thought you
said you did free Dives or something no
no that was the course that was the
course holy [__] so the course was like
you start were you start in the pool and
then you basically like go from like
zero of knowing nothing and then in
eight months or like okay now you can
teach people from zero to like just
being but you had interest in it yeah
yeah man you had to be [__] in your
pants the first time you did that uh I
was like uh you started in the pool and
you start so soft and so slow it's like
it's really incremental there was one
time where we really [__] up bad where
we uh we went on a wreck dive but there
was a group of us who weren't
recertified
um so the group that was Rec certified
went inside the wreck and this was like
in really low visibility so you like you
need to bring flashlights and [__] in
the Pacific Ocean in the Pacific Ocean
so we didn't charge our flashlights but
we went underneath the wreck because we
couldn't go inside it which is even
deeper and then we got lost and we were
like like swimming around in circles for
like what felt like an eternity when we
finally got out we like got out of the
water and they're like okay you guys
ready for the second dive and we're like
now we're just gonna we're chilling we
literally all thought we were gonna die
what kind of wreck was it that's some
big ass [__] boat underneath like
Yeah The Underneath the water like it
was like we were at the bottom of like
underneath it we were like 110 feet
under water which is like almost at the
maximum of where you can go with
recreational diving
um and you're you run out of Airway
faster down there and [__] too I'm
getting the bench just thinking yeah
dude so the college was on the coast
yeah the college was on the coast like
they put that together yeah so but the
people I'm getting a Vibe like yeah it
was probably a little baywatchy like
those people are like it totally would
have been it's a culture it was what I'm
saying it was a summer town but we were
there in the winter so it was like kind
of dead we would like do [__] like I
don't know like walk dogs and stuff to
like [__] pass the time but the group
I lived with there was five of us living
in one house and we all became like
really good friends and we would like
throw our own parties and like do
Ecstasy and like dance and [__] in the
place shout out to it yeah it was it was
a good time I take it back that is
college yeah yeah so we made the most
fun we could with like the small group
that we had and then Mexico was just a
complete [__] show and that's it you get
a job I gotta go down by yourself yeah
went down there by myself knew no one
didn't know to speak Spanish just went I
had a job awesome yeah dude you're the
coolest Canadian of all time so you were
the dude so you were the diving
instructor so you're on vacation yeah
we're gonna want to do diving you're
teaching people and you're going in yeah
I'm teaching you that's like the coolest
guy ever also I had dreadlocks at the
time too you were probably getting laid
left and right I cleaned up some pretty
like that's where my like whoring just
like really took like a instructor yeah
broke up a couple marriages yourself I
would assume there was I was there for
you yeah
of all the people who lived there there
was only one relationship that last
everyone broke up it was Playa del
Carmen Mexico it was like a huge party
vacation town people would go there be
like oh we're gonna live in Mexico and
it's like no no people are [__] and
partying out here like you don't you
don't survive out here damn yeah and it
was probably much easier from the cold
water to the nice clear waters oh it was
so nice once I made that transition and
stuff you had to be careful because we
would do stuff like shark Dives and [__]
like that so you would have to like well
watch out for for like different types
of animals and like currents and [__]
the shark Dives were sick we would go
like they would come every winter be
like Bull Shark Season you go like way
out in the into like the middle of the
ocean you drop down and you're just in
like a sand belt there's no Coral or
anything around and then you just kind
of like take a water bottle or something
and you crinkle it and they feel the
vibrations and they come and start
coming around dude that's our biggest
fear yeah it's your biggest me and Tebow
don't like sharks yeah shark oh dude
honestly I don't know like I saw a video
the other day of a great white like
busting through plexig class and trying
to eat it I just saw that yeah you saw
that yeah yeah
um I wouldn't [__] with great whites
bull sharks
you heard it here first folks tiger
sharks are cool now but the bull sharks
were chill we were even there we
wouldn't feed but they were ahead
goodbye
weed off a bull shark
he had the dreads
bam there was one time we went down and
a group was feeding the Sharks and they
were like and so we were around as they
were feeding and that was a whole other
experience because normally we would see
like four or five sharks there was maybe
20 30 sharks that came out like circling
and they're they're in a frenzy not in a
way where they're coming after you but
they're like bumping into each other and
like crashing it they want to get the
meat and then but then once all the meat
was gone within about five minutes it
went from like 30 to like 20 to like 15
to like four like they just they started
off as soon as there wasn't how many
Dives would you do a day uh on a crazy
day you would do four whoa four dies
yeah what kind of cash are we talking
about for today were you making good
money not crazy money I was probably
making something you're a 20 year old
kid or something like yeah I'm 20 year
old kid so I was probably making
somewhere between a thousand to two
thousand dollars a month like depending
on how busy it was okay uh and I was
also bartending on the side so like I
would like I would try to make a lot of
money bartending that was was where I
was making way more cash actually uh but
it was a sick time it was spending all
on condoms oh no our tendon and scuba
dive instructor I was raw dogging
everybody dude I remember one time where
I was went to go bang this girl once and
I went to put on a condom and she was
kind of like she said something to me in
Spanish and I couldn't understand it but
the body language was like why are you
using a condom and I was being like and
she was a tour she was from like Spain
or something and I was like bro like you
can't drink the water here like what the
[__]
[__] it's just strange dudes I'm just
gonna brush my teeth real quick so you
were doing this [__] hungover have you
ever yeah have you ever puked underwater
no I never puked underwater but I did
see it happen quite a few times great
question yeah that's all right how does
that work
it's like just comes out like a cloud
like a Chum probably the the way they
tell you to do it because you have your
like uh what the [__] it called again
regulator you have your regulator in
your mouth Jesus Christ you didn't know
that this guy stinks the thing on your
back the uh the [__] the tanks
the air thing it's been a long time it's
gonna be fine I'm gonna [__] your wife
make sure your tanks are on
be back in an hour so they tell you to
puke through it because you can puke
through it and what they don't want is
you to take it out and puke and then
your reaction after puking is to inhale
and then to inhale water so if you puke
through the regulator you inhale Air at
least after even if there's some chunks
and [__] in there yeah yeah so that's
something they tell you to do but I saw
people take it out and puke and then put
it back in and like you if you're paying
attention no you've got enough damn but
yeah a lot of puking people got seasick
a lot and we're just like [__] Chum
up the water like crazy how long were
you down there for uh like underwater no
you are the coolest game
[Laughter]
I'm like this dude's smooth that's all
right that's all right
one cool cat we got
um the other Canadian bozos are
shoveling snow with [__] like yeah I was
like [__] that [__] I gotta get out of
here okay let's talk about later later
later later later later let's talk about
ladder gang here's a little tip before
you decide to put the addition on a
house yourself or put the put the deck
on without any permits yeah make sure
you get yourself some ladder get
yourself covered with a little term life
insurance no doctors no needles with the
three billion dollars in coverage
they're looking out for it I'll leave
the family holding the bag yeah it's
easy peasy just answer a few questions
about your health and you'll be on your
way don't Jam someone up and after
you're long gone you've been jamming
them up your whole life take care of
them now get ahead of the problem ladder
smart algorithms work in real time so
you find out if you're instantly
approved with A and A Plus ratings by am
best and 4.8 out of 5 stars on
trustpilot you can go ahead and blindly
follow that YouTube tutorial uh with
that peace of mind if you die at least
your family won't be destitute all right
there ladder's coming to play baby yeah
so got a ladder life go to
ladderlife.com garbage today to see if
you're instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage do it gang do it
okay let's talk about that manscape baby
man Skizzy best in the business to keep
them nuts clean to keep everything clean
keep your groomed nice you got the weed
whacker 2.0 you got the Platinum package
4.0 and not to mention you got the
lawnmower 4.0 it's got a light on it so
you don't skim your nuts when you're
down there I know which I've done some
people are into that that's your
business I'm just here to tell you to
shave your gosh darn pubes
I use it on my face I don't care that's
how that's what we're doing let me say
this if you're using scissors
yeah well just we'll get an extra
election that's crazy for later combat
that's all fair coverage what are you
doing here back to manscape the best and
abyss of course lawnmower trimmer is a
total Game Changer it has 7 000 RPM
Motor Hachi mods way more than scissors
it's like a race car a spotlight so you
can see where you're up to and it's
totally waterproof I do it in a public
pool so go to so get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code garbage at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use a code
garbage use the Platinum package because
the gold stand there is no longer good
enough baby do we
how long did you do it for I was I
taught scuba diving for like two two and
a half years and then the last chunk of
time I bartended I worked at a call
center for a bit because there was like
a Canadian call center down there that
would do like HVAC calls from Mexico so
I just kind of wanted to not do the
labor job anymore and like chill out a
little bit and then in the last year was
when I started doing stand-up and you
started down there I started down there
yeah in English or Spanish in English so
there was a group of like four Dudes I
think it was like three Canadians and
one American and they just started doing
stand-up there was one show a week and I
just was like I called them once and was
like hey can I come do comedy my brother
had started doing stand-up in Canada and
I consumed stand up like crazy so I
would watch it constantly and but I
never knew you could just go do it I was
the same way yeah I thought you had to
be famous and when he was like always
like anybody can do anything and when
you do it you see the lunatics that come
to an open like oh really anyone can do
it yeah dude the the barrier for entry
is literally nothing like as long as you
can talk
um and so he was like oh yeah you just
go to Open Mic so I wrote jokes with the
intention of actually sending him the
jokes and then I wrote enough material
that I was like well I should just do it
so I went I did stand up I loved it and
it was like now I was working hard at
something and it was the first thing I
was ever like passionate you wanted to
keep getting better at it exactly so
just started grinding grinding grinding
a year into that I was like okay I wanna
do this I'm gonna move to Toronto
because that's the best place in Canada
to do it sure sold all my scuba diving
gear bought a plane ticket I went out my
flippers baby it's like this that puke
was in there when I when I bought him
that chapter was done the only guy to
take a seaplane to Toronto yeah
swam up
so I just retired all that and then when
I got to Toronto I had nothing I had
like by the time I got to downtown
Toronto I had maybe like 25 bucks uh so
I had like a little shitty laptop I
Googled Toronto homeless shelters at a
Starbucks found this like little
um it was like a Youth Shelter it was
called covenant house so it was like
anyone who was like under the age of 24
could stay there and I think it was like
22 at the time I went there they're like
we can't give you a bed we're full you
got to go to a men's shelter which is
like a much rougher environment sure
these dudes have been homeless for years
and years addicted to drugs booze all
this kind of [__] so they were like well
we can feed you so I was eating and then
when I was eating someone showed up but
they was a food like it was like it was
whatever it was like some spaghetti or
something like it would
I want to go back yeah it didn't blow my
dick off but but it was free I wouldn't
go back
service was good yeah dude service was
great it's with a smile
um but a kid showed up and he was uh he
was drunk and they're like okay well he
can't stay here tonight so you can have
a bed so then I go to bed I stayed there
for like six months and they like it was
a place to sleep they would feed you and
then I also told my move there to do
stand-ups so they would let me break
curfew to go out and do spots every
night like like just I was just [__]
doing open mics but I was just like
getting the grind doing it doing it
doing it then once that started to take
off a little bit it was like maybe six
months into staying there I moved into a
house with like all Comics sure which
was this like [__] it's probably worse
than the homeless yeah oh it was it was
no spaghetti in that house bro it was
this [__] dick home that was like famous
in Toronto because it housed like so
many comedians like do you guys know
Dave Mirage yeah yeah I did I think Dave
from hash stayed there I think Rob may
you stayed there like a like 20 years of
comics had Cycles through there yes and
it was this place where this old dude
Armando he was this deaf uh Portuguese
dude who would like come and just yell
for the rent and then if he went to go
to his place to pay the rent he would
give you this wine that he would make in
his basement that would get you [__]
yeah dude Armando what's up what's a
dude you play it fast
kids done some living yeah wait but also
go back to like the could you not have
where what did you tell your parents you
were living at a homeless shelter no no
no I didn't so my parents were divorced
at this time and my dad came to visit me
when I was staying at the shelter and he
was just he wasn't visiting me to be
like are you okay he was just visiting
me like oh you're living in Toronto now
I'll come see you uh and when I told him
everything that was going on I didn't
really think much of it I was like the
happiest I had ever been because I had a
purpose I was in a city I was doing a
thing I wanted to do like for the first
moment in my life I had like drive and
he well my uncle told me he went home
and he had dinner with my uncle and he
told me that my Dad cried being like
he's going through the struggle when I
moved to Canada I had to go through a
struggle he has to like do this part of
his life wow my dad saw it as this just
like because badge of honor this bad
yeah because he moved to Montreal he had
like a thousand dollars and he couldn't
speak English they speak French there so
he could speak French and communicate
but there's a huge part of the
population couldn't talk to I had to
teach himself English had to get a job
and go through this whole thing after
running away from Haiti because there
was a dictator in Haiti like all this
crazy [__] damn so he like they he saw
it as yeah a badge of honor kind of
thing but I didn't tell anyone I didn't
want to take help from anyone I didn't
want to take money from anyone I was
like I gotta do this on my own I gotta
figure this out
um [__] stand-up guy [__] your wife
but nice guy hard worker can't take that
from him yeah I borrowed money from my
mom a weekend
I [__] your wife but I earned it I
[__] earned it dude that's [__]
that's wild that's a [__] story holy
[__] yeah so then it was from there it
was just like grinding out in [__]
Canada to get up through like the
Canadian comedy industry I did just for
laughs and these different things and
then pandemic hit got online started
doing the tick tock that's when you
popped off on yeah you're still in
Canada for all this or did you moved
here now you moved here a year ago so
I'm in New York no [__] I am so you were
up in Canada for the pandemic for the
pandemic which was ass man our pandemic
was long yeah it was like twice as long
as your guys pandemic yeah oh can't hold
the boys damn yeah
but yeah and then yeah so like a year
ago I came here and then it was like
immediately on the road immediately like
turning this like social following into
like live shows
um and it's like convincing the audience
now because most of my online content
wasn't stand up because I we weren't
doing up there so it's like they come to
the show so like oh I didn't even know
what to expect and I'm like oh no this
is my main thing this is what I do this
is what I do I do the tick tock so you
come to the show good [__] yeah yeah
yeah [__] damn
yeah it's pretty wild pretty wild a
homeless shelter to do open mics
no no we were good on that no bed bugs
like like you said the food was okay
it's like everything was passable it was
passable and the like mics and stuff
were [__] but at least I was doing sure
yeah
um let's take a little bit of a step
back uh what was the pet situation
growing up
oh so I had one dog named Pele that was
like uh a pitbull staffy cross okay a
great dog man a little stupid
real C student huh yeah real C student
on him but like great dog he died at
like uh 10 I think okay just got like a
little too sick he started having like
seizures and stuff stayed inside parents
loved them all that kind of stuff all
that stuff yeah great dog man uh always
been a dog guy dogs are like where it's
at and did you do any jobs before you
left for for school oh yeah I was I
worked at McDonald's for a while yeah
dude oh I was one of the worst
McDonald's employees of all time did you
make your own stuff when you were in
there oh yeah I would whip [__] up in
the back all the time
dude I had like original Creations one
of the best ones
called the deep sea diver
something off the chain menu oh dude
exclusive [__] it'll clog your arteries
so you get get your McDouble okay well
I'm a classic like I love that dollar
menu [__] like double you add Mac sauce
and bacon okay cancel that One Secured
an all-time great you do and then there
was other stuff you do like a triple Big
Mac stuff like that sure
um and I was trying I did some dessert
[__] too oh yeah if you take an apple
pie you've I think this has gone public
now but you take an apple pie and you
put it in McFlurry and like Whip It Up
in there 100 yeah that that is like a
killer absolutely like they're trading
it on the stock market yeah
I made a killing in it you can invest I
remember it was just a few people those
are the real people yeah I got it when
it was a penny stock man it's huge
how do you think he funded [__]
Mexico uh okay uh growing up did you
drink milk with dinner uh I didn't
actually I think I might have I did
drink a lot of milk but I don't know if
it was a milk with dinner kid okay but I
drank a ton of milk I remember I used to
do this thing where Doritos were big in
my house I would sit in my house
no one knew about those no no no we were
first under pitos but we get those big
Costco bags of Doritos like a giant one
and I would sit there with a glass of
milk and like a bowl full of Doritos and
I would fill my mouth with so many
Doritos and chew it until it was like
this Dorito paste and then it would take
a swig of milk and like Cannonball it
down sure that was just a system in my
head where I was like this is the way so
you're a biting sugar or bite and sip
you'll will you do that with any meal uh
not any meal the Doritos was a specific
thing to get consistency I wanted this
consistency you're making concrete oh
yeah absolutely what was coming out the
other end was [__] bro yeah a couple
bricks yeah
um all right so how was the family
dinner set up would you guys have dinner
as a family every night we did for a
while and then my sister moved out
because she was 10 years older right and
then the family dinner thing kind of
dissolved and that was also my parents
marriage and like dissolving and me
trying to like not be home as much as
possible so we did do family dinners for
a long time but the family dinner was
also the place where you got ambushed
like been there baby talk about getting
flanked from both sides yeah you sure
you ain't Irish that was the when you go
so you did this or we caught you doing
this or your report card someone so
called yeah and you're like bro I
realized years later where you get
ambushed you get ambushed bro I was
eating with my shoulders up and really
fast and he's in jail yeah I was like oh
this is like old drama that I gotta like
relax when you take a bite put your fork
down chill because I was eating like a
[__] animal because that was the most
stressful situation yeah exactly hit the
biggest guy at the table yeah
hit your dad with your tray says
that's my cornbread wow damn any any any
specific Delicacies that your mom would
put after was she did she have any home
run hits oh my parents Great Cooks okay
dude you said your dad was Haitian your
mom was just regular yeah just regular
Canadian her background was like French
and Dutch and [__] but that never really
came into the mix but both like big on
cooking like Christmas dinners all that
stuff huge our house everything made
from scratch I love that bro like wait
like Christmas time my mom would make
all these desserts and [__] there was
like pecan Puffs which were like these
little balls that had like pecans and
all this [__] in it and it was like
dough she would make this stuff I can't
remember what the [__] it was called but
it was like a bark where it was like a
caramel base that was hard and it had
almond slivers in it and then melted
chocolate on top and it was broken into
all these little pieces it's called
crack yes yes
down here they call it crack it's uh
there's something like saltine crackers
are on the bottom usually we we didn't
do it with the saltines but I know what
you're talking about yeah yeah yeah and
it would like all the uh butter tart so
you guys don't really have butter tarts
here butter tarts I got an eye on it a
butter tartar is basically like a mini
pecan pie okay yeah and all this [__]
made from scratch that's nice and then
we would do Haitian food for the
Christmas dinner so we do like kratzine
which is like it's basically like cheese
pasta meat cheese pasta meat lamby which
is like a conch shell a curried goat uh
rice and peas all this [__] like all
like boom home run hits dude tons of
great [__] food in the house okay
love that did you guys ever watch any TV
as a family would you watch shows
together we were big big TV house we
would um like the news was always on
when the news was on sure um we would do
like the office and stuff reality TV was
big in the house my mom was a big
Survivor person who wasn't at that time
though man that took that took the World
by storm watching survivors family
that's all right Survivor was huge my
parents both loved anything where people
get hurt if someone's gonna
my like their marriage yes one of my
earliest memories yeah I was like maybe
four I'm on a seesaw I eat it off of the
CSUN fall into the wood chips and I'm
like kind of stunned in days and I'm
young enough where I'm like I'm kind of
waiting for my mom to come pick me up
and then no one comes and I realize I
kind of got to take I get up I brush
myself off and I realized no one has
come because I can see my mom and she's
keeled over like on all fours laughing
so hard that she physically can't come
here
[Laughter]
what were the family vacations like
growing up bro toxic
man we're like 400 episodes in that's
the best response yeah dude away games
dude yeah no the the family uh vacations
were a burden we would go
together no one wanted to go together I
remember one time uh me uh it was just
me my dad my mom we drove down from uh
Vancouver all the way down to California
to go Disneyland so it's like a
multi-day drive okay and we're driving
we're stopping my parents are getting
like what kind of car we talking uh this
was a Jeep [__] what was it called oh
[__] Cherokee no no it wasn't the
Cherokee Wrangler no it was one that was
like a little bit more like family
oriented oh the the Wagoneer no [__]
what was it called I was in an SUV it
was SUV yeah it wasn't that weird thing
the Jeep used to make with the big tires
was it no I don't think so [__] I can't
remember the name of this but it was for
sure a Jeep okay my mom was crazy about
this car because she got like a free car
every three years with her job all right
it was like a driving meeting people and
[__]
um but we drove all the [__] way down
okay and a part way was it this thing
no no it wasn't that it was more modern
think like this would have been I would
have been like 10 so this would be like
200 uh four and this car was pretty new
so whatever jeep was cooking out in
around like 2004 2005. okay
um so good car good car nice cool car
yeah it was a good car that's a good car
um so we were like maybe halfway down to
California maybe a little closer and my
mom's in like a mood today and she's
just kind of like cooking and my dad's
like whoa whatever and she goes like
what's going on today and he's like uh
uh I don't know I mean she's like
it's my birthday oh yeah any swinging a
miss and my dad goes isn't it on Tuesday
and she goes no and he goes I'm sticking
with Tuesday
I respect that his feet his heels are
dug in dude legendary move by my dad
talk about shaking things up
you're in the back oh yeah headphones on
we're stuck in a car together for the
next [__] I don't know how many days
then at Disneyland together God damn did
you remember her birthday ah no I did
not I did I absolutely did not I don't
remember birthdays that's uh I got them
from my dad Jesus yikes do you remember
your first concert
um first concert [__] I think I went to
see Wyclef Jean with my dad that was
pretty good yeah so that was the first
one I went to go see at his height I
would imagine yeah yeah yeah I remember
white cleft White Cliff was like the
middle act but he stole the show you
[__] killed it and he came out in
like uh super Talent oh he's crazy
talented dude at one point he was like
playing the guitar with his teeth and
then he brought a lady on stage and
played the guitar with his teeth in her
lap to be like yo I'm eating your [__]
kind of thing yeah yeah he came out in
like a Luchador mask and like a rope
like a wrestler walked through the crowd
got on stage then took off his uh his
robe and he's wearing a Canucks lawongo
Jersey and people went like [__] ah
yeah dude it was like funny I just gotta
work a crap yeah never been bit by any
animals snake lizard Birds anything like
that no oh yeah when I was scuba diving
once I got bit by this green moray so
Amore eel yeah yeah so there was uh
there was this green moray that was
always in the same spot and she was like
very friendly but she was huge she was
probably like five feet long okay
[__] head on them real thick head
it's like a Mack truck coming at you so
I saw this morning so many times I built
a little bit of a relationship with it
like I would pass the homie dude
yeah
damn dude what's your problem
we were boys man we were boys
but I came through one time like I would
come through and you would put your hand
in front of the Maury's face and pull it
out and she would follow it so she'd
come out of the cave so the the what the
[__] Addy the people was diving with him
like look you can see this whole morning
she would never [__] around but we
went one time and she was real
aggressive like keeping her mouth open
and maybe she had kids or eggs or some
[__] in there she was protecting having
a bad day somebody forgot her birthday
yeah
sticking with Tuesday
but she when I put my hand in to [__]
bring her out she bit down on my hand
and then uh she didn't she like didn't
Shake try to bite it off she bit and
then held there for a second released
and then went back to the same position
I was like all right I'll [__] off
not too bad there was like a little I
think there's still a little bit of a
scar there or was it on this hand no I
think it was this one I don't think you
can even oh yeah there I can see it yeah
yeah there was like [__] out just
like a little hole yeah it was a little
hole it wasn't bad like it didn't feel
good but yeah Jesus yeah
um but that yeah that was that's the
most significant animal bite I ever had
yeah okay that's not great did you have
a car up there when you were a kid no I
never got a car my dad let me drive his
truck around for a little bit you've
never owned a car never owned a car no
no no uh I had my like Learners uh like
you're basically like your stage one a
driving license thing and then I got to
like the stage two and then I started
traveling I like lost everything I had
to start from scratch so do you have a
license I have a license now I wouldn't
got my when I was in Toronto I got my
license yeah we have a Canadian license
no yeah no New York Life yes when's the
first time you were on a plane first
time I was on a plane [__] I was
I was definitely young my parents got me
flying at a young age one of my earliest
flights I think was to Chicago to go
visit some family but I was so young I
don't really remember the flight so then
you had your passport too at a young
yeah yeah my parents got me they that
one thing they were like you're learning
how to swim you're getting a passport
like little life things that are like
sure pain in the ass to do when you're
older learn how to ride a bike all that
kind of [__] they got they're like we're
getting all this done we're getting all
this you're not you're never gonna have
to fight to get your passport your
[__] social security number all that
[__] it's all [__] done yeah okay I
respect that it really prepared you yeah
yeah okay let's talk about fitbod baby
oh baby you want to talk about fitbot
zoom in I'm down 10 pounds gang it
doesn't matter it doesn't have to be New
Year's Day for you to make New Year's
resolutions shake up that old workout
routine with fitbod baby starting a new
routine and shaking things up can be
difficult but it's easy with fitbod
fitbot uses AI technology to create a
custom workout plan based on your
personal goals experience the equipment
you have available and more yeah gang
it's uh it's really easy it keeps track
all your gym sessions by mixing up your
workouts keeps tracks of your
achievements your personal best the
whole nine yards I did two push-ups
yesterday hit me lucky you
you already use the technology to get
directions talk to people across the
world and you to see what AI thinks
about your future baby is going to look
like so why not use it to enhance your
workouts you know what I mean couple of
Meat Heads like us sure that's what we
need you can learn new movements the
right way with over 1400 demo videos
there you go and fitbots Technology even
studies your past workouts and assesses
your progress to keep things challenging
and fun and here's the turkey baby
low-fat turkey it's not too late to
crush the summer fitness goals try
fitbot today get 25 off your
subscription or try the app free at
fitbod.me garbage that's fitbot
fitbod.me garbage do it gang it's good
[__] did you play hockey as a kid no I
was a boxer I boxed what yeah yeah you
did yeah I boxed from the age of 12 to
16 on a team no it wasn't you're at a
gym okay yeah you're at a gym and you
like box with your guys at the gym and I
had 12 amateur fights I did
foreign
Toby get the mitts let's see what he's
made of damn holy [__] because you're a
pretty big dude you're a man of stats
you're Southpaw right hand I'm no I'm
I'm Orthodox I'm an orthodox okay
um but yeah can you tune us up I haven't
fought in a long time I started taking
some Muay Thai classes recently okay yes
let's back that up a bit
Muay Thai is that near Seattle what are
we talking about here
damn all right yeah man have you ever
had to use your your boxing knowledge in
real life because you seem like a real
chill laid back no I've never been in a
street fight I got jumped one time when
I was a kid like I was I was hanging out
with two buddies I wouldn't do anything
my hands
he's a registered yeah
no the yellow came back with some
friends
quick grab the scuba gear
but yeah I got jumped one time and a guy
punched me in the face a couple times
and I was with two girls and he was with
like four dudes and I just kind of like
he punched me and he was like yo [__]
you dude I like gave his girlfriend a
high five didn't know his girlfriend was
my first time meeting these people no
idea and he punched me a couple times in
the face and then I was just kind of
like yo and there's I was like I just
walked away sure because I'm like yeah
it's a five on one self-preservation
yeah I'm like I'm just unless these
broads can [__] roll
yo how's your Jujitsu Sally you've been
training up
hey Tina you take the big one
um let's talk about now a little bit uh
uh you got your own place or you got
roommates so I got my own place yeah all
right one bedroom New York I've been
living on my own for a while now things
are going well things are going well
like once the brand deals started coming
in for the Social and I started getting
three Deals it was it was [__] sick
nice nice like you know you start stand
up and you don't know where it's gonna
go you think it's going nowhere yeah
essentially and I was always like I'm
like I'm just gonna keep focused on
getting funnier and I'm just gonna keep
working and now I'm making more money
than I ever thought I would make I'm not
making like an insane like I'm gonna
[__] buy a boat or something sure but
I don't worry for [__] I can save like
the opportunity to buy a house is in my
future right that's amazing yeah of
course good [__] yeah have you made any
stupid purchase or anything you look
back and like I didn't when you got your
first check or anything oh I don't I'm
really not like I'm I I don't buy [__]
really are you a saver I'm a saver I
like I spend I try to reinvest in the
career like I need to pay an editor I
need to hire these people that kind of
thing yeah my big purchase after my
first road run where I like made money
when I first came to the States was a TV
I got a nice TV and I I always I stand
by a nice TV is like the most important
part of the house sure but you still got
that same TV oh yeah that team's not
even a year old yet yeah so I just got
that bad boy like oh I love it bro 55.
what are you talking about oh I think
it's like a 65. yeah heavy bike in a one
bedroom too it's like it's my the 65 and
my beds right what is the uh let's talk
about the apartment a little bit what's
the bet is it a king queen single it's a
king but I moved man when I moved in
there it was already there I would have
gone Queen because just there's not a
lot of stuff I'm sorry I'm sorry back
that up yeah do you say you when you
moved into the apartment the bed was
already there it was already there yeah
does it make that make sense so when I
moved in if they were like oh girl who
lived here before she's Russian and she
had to leave to go get her like
paperwork fixed and so she could come
back to America okay because I think
this one like the Ukraine [__] was like
popping off yeah so she's gonna go
enlist take my beard oh
she left a bunch of [__] behind but I
moved to New York with like two
suitcases and a backpack so you needed a
bed anyway yeah so I was like they were
like oh we'll take it out of here and I
was like ah leave it it was a girl like
it's like it can only be something a
girl's bed psychologically yeah of
course you checked it for bed bugs yeah
yeah yeah I checked I checked the bad
boy checked the place everything was
good and I was like all right we're good
we're cooking on this that's good I mean
that's that's a blemish in the record
but it is a king it's a king-sized it's
a king also if there's a king size more
of a Kaiser I do nothing on that I think
that's German I think it is this is all
aren't they Czar yeah yeah
um okay so you got the king-sized bed
yeah which is crazy it's the comforter
situation the comforter just the regular
[__] from Target I'm a simple man okay
yeah yeah just got the regular sheets
and stuff from Target okay throw that on
there we're good how many how many
pillows are on that two pillows you got
two pillows one for me one for when
there's a guest has anybody else picked
up he says milk and pillow just like
Foley oh yeah I'll do that too the ease
in there yeah milk and pillow I I've
been called on that several times nice
pillow and a glass of milk yeah dude
um so you only sleep with one pillow
yeah yeah yeah on your side or on your
back I'm a back sleeper yeah you sleep
on your back man that's real vampire
with one pillow one pillow on the back
in the king size usually like yeah right
in the center man that's what I'm doing
so you're so I walk into your room
you're laying there like this
um I don't know if the hands would be on
the chest it's a [__] vampire it's
got his Dukes up yeah your hands on your
side yeah maybe on the side maybe
they're kind of like thrown about a
little bit like I might be maybe leaning
to one side more than the other like
it's not a perfect line I'm not coming
out of it like a coffin like oh I just
raise up the Undertaker yeah uh okay you
got an AC unit in there I got two okay a
room or two in the apartment two in the
apartment no it's it's a it's a a studio
so it's just like okay everything's just
fine who crank it in the stew so I had
oh that's chilly I had to get one right
away when I moved there because it was a
brutal summer super hot people who don't
live in New York tonight it's [__]
gets broken like stinky sweaty smells
like piss everywhere like so you're like
I gotta cool this place off
um but then my neighbor she got a new
one and I like bring her packages up for
her and stuff and so she was like oh I'm
getting like do you want this like and I
was like all right I'll put it in the
window so sometimes when it's cooking
real hot or I I don't leave them on when
I'm not there or anything I come back
turn them both on and the whole place is
cooled off studio apartment with a
decent air conditioner man that's really
cooling it down oh yeah that's all right
okay you sleep with the TV on when you
go to bed no I'm pitch black I got my
blackout curtains sometimes I wear an
eye mask I'm a big like I sleep so the
arms cross question wasn't insane
studio apartment you're all by yourself
yeah you have blackout curtains yeah
when you go to bed it's completely dark
in there completely dark I wear the
sleep mask I turn on the AC it's gonna
be cold in the room like I'm big on all
my like sleep hygiene in quotations that
I gotta sleep really you're sleeping in
a used bed
[__] quote high jeans okay what are
we talking about but man that's
confidence that's that's not a lot of
anxiety to be able to go to bed like oh
man I'm on a five story walk up you want
to come up and [__] kill me
come up and catch these hands he's still
got the blindfold them growing Hooks and
you're also you're down on cardio by the
time you get there I'll take you into
deep water
I'm fresh and ready to go I'm not taking
the 12th round baby ten and two [__]
ten and two let's see them legs all
right man that's wild I'll take you into
deep water
[Laughter]
you're nuts
I take back everything I said I thought
you were cool you're just a crazy person
sleeping nude with a mask on what's in
the Pitch Black it's 32 degrees in there
man if a burglar did walk in they would
back the [__] out immediately I don't
know what this guy's did too but I don't
want no vacation Hogs floating around
okay take the mask off the Iceman
[__] scooping gear next to the fridge
Jesus dude holy holy [__] man this one's
from cool to Psycho he leaves the door
open
come on in if you dare likes to
encourage welcome them crazy oh man oh
man what about the shower shower you
peeing in the shower oh yeah brushing
your teeth in there uh sometimes not all
the time I got the electric guy so I
don't like to bring it in the shower
what's that electric toothbrush look
like is there a lot of is that a lot of
coding on that gunk in there no so I'm
really good about rinsing it off because
I had one before and it started to look
like a horror show those things okay
puts yeah dude I left one at my buddy's
house one time my buddy Pat it was mine
and then I was like I was going back to
next weekend he brought it to him he's
like
do me to change this yeah this is really
[__] bad it looks fossilized it looks
a lot of calcium
a couple stalactites it's real got the
landlord special
little white paint over this bad boy oh
man okay
you're flossing you're flossing a big
flosser yeah big floss guy yeah there's
certain things like certain I'm like I
constantly like walk that line of like
being a horrible piece of [__] and like
trying to be as good as possible okay so
like eating clean and stuff like right
now I'm on a real good clean kick but as
soon as I have like two tequila sodas
I'll be like [__] jerking off and
order an Uber Eats and stay in bed all
day like that'll be the the next one on
the Uber yeah it's pretty cool uh you're
cooking I assume you're cooking at the
house yeah cook I'm not cooking anything
too fancy I got one of those keeping it
tight yeah chicken breast and something
exactly I I one thing I did a big
expense I bought was I bought like nice
beef I got like uh Frozen beef brought
in from like a grass finished farm so
it's like good quality [__] gotcha
yeah respect you got a full-size fridge
in there fridge and freezer yeah
full-sized fridge freezer gas stove or
electric stove yes okay yeah cooking on
the gas okay okay where do you eat now
you make your grass-finished beef and
broccoli is there a little table in
there no little tables I'm either
standing there's like a little like
countertop I'm eating there or I go
right to the bed and I'm just [__]
learning there's no kitchen oh yeah
there's no couch in this apartment no
couch no it's just a bed and a TV bad TV
like it's got the TV stand I got a
dresser and then I have like my whole
computer set up on top of the dresser so
I have like a standing desk kind of
scenario yeah
that's real that's real True Detective
Vibes right there okay that guy's
there's a lot of red red yarn in there
from picture to picture is it like a
gaming PC is there a lot of like RGB
lights in general yeah I just got this
bad boy it's like a full like it's got a
40 70 in it or something like it's a
beast he's a huge [__] nerd yeah
video games that's one thing with the TV
like one of my big indulgences my big
indulgences are like booze food porn and
games those are like the things that's
everybody yeah
just a regular guy
you got the PS5 or your Xbox PS5 PS5
because all the Xbox stuff you can get
on on PC now so I just [__] rock the
PC and PS5 that's and then I have a
switch for when I travel were you always
playing video games as a kid did you
have all that [__] when you were a kid
yeah one of my earliest memories is
playing uh NES like and we lived in a
house from the time I was like one to
four and I remember in that house
playing the NES like uh one of The
Simpsons games back in the day yeah yeah
wait for you said one to four and then
where did you move uh then we moved so
we uh we lived in uh Port Moody you
won't know where that but then we moved
to like where I lived with the most of
my childhood that was a house yeah yeah
okay hmm you got a favorite cereal uh oh
uh Cinnamon Toast Crunch 100 cinnamon
man you have a favorite flavor of
Pringles oh I'm not a big Pringles guy
I'm not crazy huge usually when I go
chips I like a sour cream and onion
that's my go-to or barbecue those are
like what's your brand if you're if
you're indulging and you you what's like
all right I'm gonna indulge I gotta get
ketchup chips that they have in Canada
we do have ketchup chips I'm not crazy
about the ketchup chips we do have them
but I'm like Heather whatever
um I like um uh do you guys don't really
have Ruffles down here dude yeah oh you
got Ruffles
okay you guys look at Toby he's gonna
hit you
[__] Ruffles built this country young
man
you know sour cream and cheddar shout
out to it but you don't have all dressed
you don't have all dressed Ruffles
that's a Canadian [__] great
it's like everything it's like kind of
like vinegary but also kind of barbecuey
like there's a bunch of [__] going on on
it fully they take every flavoring they
have salt and vinegar ketchup barbecue
and they put it on one channel we got
that [__] down yeah all dressed chips by
Ruffles are exactly what they sound like
potato chips flavor with all the
dressings ketchup salt vinegar barbecue
sour cream onion and other mystery
seasonings yeah what the [__] Vinnie
ordered me some chips Bro [__] ketchup
chips ketchup chips they ain't got [__]
on the Ruffles
that's a [__] chip holy [__]
yeah that's pretty good
tuxedo chips
have you drank out of a water fountain
in the last 365 days ah I don't think so
maybe I have there's always one at the
gym so like you you're [__] you're
making one of them I'll give you yeah
yeah
um are there any milk crates in your
apartment right now no okay you wash
your fruit if you get fruit I feel like
I should but I never do any magnets on
the fridge
not now there was I used to have my old
place I the magnets didn't make it but I
used to have magnets and then my nieces
sent like made me little cards like hey
we love you Uncle Che like happy
birthday and like nice and those were up
on the fridge pretty close with the
family now right yeah yeah yeah
absolutely good good good uh I'm sorry
no please How many pairs of dress shoes
do you own one one you got any suits no
do you know how to tie a tie no
you own a belt yes if you were if you
had a if you had somebody was like hey I
have a corporate gig tomorrow yeah it
pays something that you go I gotta do it
but you gotta dress nice yeah what what
do you have currently in your wardrobe
that you would string together you're
running out I have one like look that is
like this nice pair you just see this
look this like start with a nice sleep
mask
s
[Laughter]
okay so like I have one pair of like
dress shoes dress pants dress shirt one
like and it's just and one belt that I
got for a wedding like that's not the
okay yeah
all right where's pants what khakis uh
dress pants or cat oh they're dress
pants dress pair of slacks yeah because
you put a Blazer on over it and not look
like yeah no you know you would look
cute where did you get this
um oh [__] where did I get it I I was
with a I was dating a girl at the time
it was her brother's wedding and she
took me to this place and they were I
was like I need clothes and they were
like all right where was the wedding at
he was the only one not wearing a sport
coat uh no I don't think so okay um it
was in uh Regina Saskatchewan that's not
anything no Regina
the city that rhymes with fun that's the
classic Regina joke
nothing on that
router is dead
okay all right did you say it was in the
summer uh no it wasn't in the summer it
was no sport coated no sport coat yeah
it's a winner yeah no it was definitely
I remember there's snow on the ground
there was definitely snow on the ground
and Regina is a cold place too right in
there
you gotta heat it up a little bit a
little bit of foreplay what are you
doing yeah well you wearing a t-shirt
underneath this this this uh dress shirt
no I think I just went dress shirt bear
on the skin okay good good all right man
would you guys give a gift at that
wedding oh
before you were making a little cash uh
this was before I was making a little
cash I was still I was broke as hell
back then we did get one bottle of
tequila because I was meeting her
parents for the first time I got her
parents like a nice bottle of tequila
did you yeah yeah I did that all right
yeah half drunk
yeah you better hurry up
you want to pull off this okay all right
um so you do a lot of traveling now are
you TSA pre-check no I can't get it
because I'm Canadian what's the deal so
you have to have like America
yeah at least a green card to get the
pre-check yes I could do like Global
Entry but to get Global Entry is going
to be like [__] 18 months or
something and by then I'll probably have
my green card yes okay okay yeah but I
would love to do pre-check man you
putting the seat back when you get on a
plane always always the whole seat back
known yes no I'm like you put the it it
has the function now it goes back it
goes back we do it the guy I hate on the
[__] plane the one who opens the
window I can't stand that drives me
crazy what are we all doing on the plane
we're all looking at screens or sleeping
that's what we're doing we need Darkness
it needs to be [__] how you hate me
oh you're a [__] uh dude I'll make
him in The Hideout he's looking for UFO
yeah I got a little UFO check when I get
up there yeah I go up and down like just
in case if we fly over something cool we
saw the Hoover Dam flew to Vegas that
was pretty sweet I I like the idea that
you don't keep it open always you're
like I'm gonna catch them I'm gonna have
UFO sense yeah just when they think I'm
sleeping
like the guy in the spaceship is like
Jesus
that fat man just stole us we're screwed
Tommy I am turning the wheels all right
I'll bored abort all right buddy pull it
over
you've always been drinking
will you bring food on the plane uh
sometimes yeah I'll grab some snacks
anything egregious like you're not like
a burger or something no a package good
yeah well I'm a big pistachio guy like a
good person yeah
you like him in the Shell I like if I
can get him without the shell get him
without the shell I'll I'll be lazy you
ever do the red ones no I've never had
the red ones yeah the real old school
yeah they're dyed they're dyed pink for
some reason yeah my stepdad and his
mouth would be all pink around the
holidays yeah just [__] cooking them
just to go back to the seat thing will
you
will you give a heads up or are you
jamming it back I do like uh like a slow
like I'm like it's coming and this isn't
it Meal Time right that the trays let me
know yeah all right I do I do I I like I
I ease into it all right you sit in
first class they're still in the back I
still in the back I never I never
grabbed the first class I'm like it's
it's good enough will you ever go up is
there is there were you like all right
I'll get there are you looking forward
to it you're going I'm a back of the I'm
a back of the bus sometimes I pass it
like I think if I start doing crazy long
flights like if I can do six hours in
the back and like that's across the
country so that's fine it's like if I'm
doing if I start flying to like Europe a
lot or something I'm doing nine hour
flights then maybe uh sure I'll do it if
I do something I go to Japan once maybe
I'll pay for the first class okay is
that where you'd like to go is that I
would love to go to Japan yeah Japan
seems cool as [__] you doing any
vacations now have you gotten away or
done anything so I got one coming up at
the end of the month I'm going to Greece
for a wedding first time ever going to
Europe fantastic going to Greece what
are you going to Greece uh it yeah I'm
I'm leaving the 25th I'm there for a
week so I got like three days in Athens
that I'm going to Crete to keep meet the
wedding party nice then I got uh 24
hours in Amsterdam and then I'm taking
off to Berlin
you were gonna miss that flight to
Berlin dude
nothing that's got a wedding in Crete uh
my buddy and
actually a guy would go on the road with
in Canada we did a bunch of Tours
together so it's like an old comedy
buddy nice and he's getting married he's
been with the same girl since like he
was like 16 like only girls ever been
with high school sweetheart kind of
thing wedding in Greece and grease man
yeah but I'm like I've never been here
you're gonna have to get a new pair of
slacks for that one are you gonna are
you gonna get a news no Regina slacks so
I got it so it's like a it's a it's hot
there that time of year so I got like a
whole bunch of like uh with linen white
linen kind of [__] going on yeah yeah
okay okay all right how long are you
gonna be in Berlin uh for a week a week
in Berlin yeah are you going to get
weird oh yeah yeah I'm gonna go to that
place KitKat yeah yeah Kit Kats this
like 24 hour sex club that you can go to
and you just go and [__] a bunch and I'm
meeting this girl there who like a girl
had messaged me off of uh she actually
emailed me but the email goes to my
manager my manager sent me this thing
hey this chick wants to [__] you yeah
she was like it was basically like a few
pictures of her nothing like nude or
anything but she was like hey my name's
Sarah I'm from my Iceland I'm in my Eat
Pray Love era I just like I would love
to meet up with you and she's cute as
hell and so we started talking and then
she's like I go to Berlin a lot I was
like well I'm going to Greece if I go to
Berlin will you meet me there she's like
yeah I'll come meet you in Berlin and so
I'm gonna go meet her in Berlin and then
yeah we're gonna [__] get weird it's
pretty [__] cool pretty got a good
one yeah line it up got a line he's
living the [__] dream he's not
checking out museums and [__] Heimer
like you are I don't know so where in
your apartment do you have your radish
Canadian award yeah is that in your
baddest Canadian you're the raddest
Canadian of all time
you ruled dude dude I've been living
I've been living yeah it's all right and
you're a younger guy too how old are you
33 31 31. what's the credit score like
no clue right so in Canada I never built
credit C minus yeah
yeah so I started building Credit in
America now it's like Fresh Start in
Canada I never built credit what's the
credit limit do you know
um on my credit card so I had to get
like because I'm brand new we just went
I mean we went through it I had to get
like a safe car
yeah so that was yeah I know we just we
just went through all this like 18
months ago oh really you guys just got
into the credit system yeah so I yeah it
was like five thousand it was the limit
I think yeah dude they started me at
200. really 200 bucks damn
it was like I just hit the like seven or
eight months in order now it's like
seven or something like right what do
you what are you rocking what do you got
Amex you got MasterCard Visa I'm Visa
Visa guys there's a Visa man yeah do you
have a specific carrier that you like to
fly to uh Delta do you have a Delta card
like oh I got I got a Delta count so I
got the points okay but yeah I don't
have a Delta card uh does any of those
credit cards in your wallet have the
activation stickers still on it no no no
[Laughter]
uh have you ever saved a Crown Royal bag
no I've never saved a Crown Royal bag
I'm not a big Crown Royal guy yeah I'm a
tequila drinker send venmo requests uh
no venmo's not big in Canada he's a Zell
man I just went through this yeah I
didn't know my Zell yeah he's like give
me your Zell and I was like I don't even
know what email I like Zell because
Zell's the same as what we have in
Canada it's e-transfer which is right
from bank to bank and in every Bank in
Canada uses it and it's free yeah you
know like venmo or nothing like that up
there yeah yeah
let me ask you this all right let's say
you go out to dinner with uh with the
young lady yeah you go out to dinner
you get a salmon yeah or whatever
she orders a pizza yeah like a pizza for
herself yeah if you find that strange if
you order the pizza as an entree no I
don't find that strange okay this guy
checks out
he gives me [__] Toby cut that
[Music]
and now you're dying on that one T-Bone
I have executive cut it stays I have
Final Cut oh how many bathing suits do
you own one
okay it's probably a pair of basketball
shorts no I have one legit bathing suit
that I got for free that my buddy had
like this fashion brand that he was
trying to blow up and he's like you want
a pair and I was like yeah yeah undies
what are you doing uh I buy buy the bag
uh like Fruit of the Loom kind of [__]
yeah
oh yeah yeah just like oh I get a gross
of them you buy them by the pounds I go
through them uh I'm a boxer brief guy
like I like the leg coverage yeah of
course
hmm
how many you got silverware at the house
I got one fork
that's like what are we even doing
how else is this in the Canadian spy
supposed to live yeah no [__] he's gonna
be a sky Parker for the company yeah uh
did you steal that no no it was there
when I got there
it's a wrap holy [__] dude there was
like a few things how do you come across
one foot you can't buy one say it yeah
the girl left behind a few things there
was like two forks and Like a Knife I'm
not crazy and I think I threw out one by
accident and I even I when I first moved
there I wasn't cooking at all I was only
eating out and then when I started
cooking I opened the oven for the first
time after like six or seven months of
living there and I found a frying pan I
was like oh I got a pan now
I'm still living like a homeless guy
the steak that was in it was pretty good
A little chewy I mean yeah yeah
full-blown trash sure
Wildlife you bite your nails you clip
them clip them okay yeah no bite or no
yeah
I mean yeah
colored contacts anybody color contacts
no no color contacts you like egg salad
uh egg salad yeah I'll eat it sometimes
yeah
hey are you are you guys if you want
like the real like a real garbage thing
about me yeah please the uh I've had
chlamydia six times check please that's
the most probably garbage thing about me
six times six times yeah yeah it's like
I just would I don't know you're a young
man what the heck is trying to get it
who gets it six times it just kept
popping up for like a little while the
same girl I don't know what's going on
yeah man uh that's 100 Canadian garbage
yeah but you're killing it yeah Wildlife
Wildlife great career yeah this guy has
lived at 31. yeah yeah no he's already
gonna live been good Jesus God damn the
toxic vacations the eel the Russian bed
yeah one four one four
man the dog sounded nice though sounds
like a cute dog you guys had it for a
little bit in the early 2000s it all
fell apart man holy [__] yeah no
definitely yeah no I figured out that's
how I was gonna play it yeah did you I
pre-approved myself this morning
what a ten thousand dollar credit limit
yeah you're the Michael Jordan of
chlamydia
it's like a condom brand
chain Arena ladies and gentlemen yeah
fantastic 100 Canadian garbage [__]
fantastic comedian buddy you're killing
it [__] we love you man that was just
so much fun what do you got what do you
got coming up you want to plug away any
dates whatever it doesn't matter that's
you right there oh there's one here
right there okay uh yeah I'm uh so I'm
gonna be in uh Fort Wayne Indiana uh in
September also I'm gonna be Austin's in
September Raleigh and September we got
Denver coming up uh [__] what else is
cooking oh we got all the Midwest [__]
uh Wisconsin we're doing Madison and uh
Appleton and we also got uh Minneapolis
is coming and then some December [__]
hasn't been announced yet uh but we're
gonna have Jersey in there we're gonna
have Connecticut in there and there's
one other place I can't remember those
tickets aren't live but if you're in
those areas [__] coming to Waters
kids moving some tickets yeah it does
well we're doing good we're doing good
out here on the road buddy
congratulations congrats on everything
super funny this was so much [__] fun
thank you man I appreciate that for him
uh we're all over the road as well shows
herself on out we're adding them in a
lot of places but not every place so if
you're waiting on your tickets don't
scoop them up scoop them up now uh also
Philly's already sold out we're kicking
around the idea adding another [__]
Showdown air which we're gonna need your
help let's get some [__] tickets gang
we love you gang we love you we'll see
you next week peace